Charles is in Rochester New York hey
Charles how are you good how are you
better than I deserve what's up um so
I'm on baby set to me my wife and I had
I both had a whole both had individual
whole life policies mm-hmm and after
discovering you I canceled them and took
the cash payout and I'm putting that
towards baby step two but when I told
the insurance guy that you know like you
know I I called him and explained you
know what I wanted to do and he was a
little upset and he started to give me
the line and then you know when he when
you when I explained why and you know
where I got the advice from he really
went overboard I'm being upset and I'm
just he just got so upset and I just
want to make sure I did the right thing
a and B he was I have my disability
policy through him and I have a term
life policy through him as well
and I and I said you know I'd still like
to stay with your with you but and he
said he'd reach out to me later have his
assistant or someone and I just I don't
know he was just kind of rude about it
and I okay so I go I go into a restroom
I go into a restaurant and I say you
know it's a steakhouse and I really
don't want steak I'm gonna order your
salmon and so the waiter gets upset and
choose me out why would I go back to
that restaurant I know I just feel bad
because why why do you feel bad you're
the customer the guy's being a jerk as
customer yeah eat man you should have
heard him one you found out yeah I
talked to you about it oh my they don't
like he does not like whole life agents
don't like you canceling whole life
policies that should not be a shock yeah
and he he he tried to tell me that you
know if I just waited two more years
that would have doubled and uh-huh it's
a bunch of horse crap
listen Europe you're a nice person then
you don't like conflict but you need to
know that you need to think about what
just happened to you you're the customer
yeah and your your your company that is
yelling at their customer they're upset
with their own customer that's absurd I
don't care what you do you do whatever
you want to do you called me and number
one yes you did the right thing to
cancel your whole life and always make
sure you have the proper amount of term
insurance in place before you do that I
told you that before right
yep I'm well he was I guess I'm gonna go
to Xandar and look Herman I wanted to
give him I just I had loyalty I guess em
and they haven't gotten back to me I
gave him a week do you think that I
don't know I just listened fast and I
get well yeah it's not old-fashioned
you're just a kind person but I got to
tell you I'm not that kind because if
I'm the customer and the waiter starts
chewing me out
you're gonna salmon and a steakhouse
what's wrong with you
well what's wrong with me is I made the
choice to sit down at your table and
stay in your place so you can take this
whole place and stick it in your ear and
I'm walking out of there you know I
can't there's no way I'm doing that I'm
not putting up with I'm not somebody
attitude that's taking my money yeah so
you're doing say one more thing issued
since I found you I just want anyone out
there listening who's you know I don't
make that much money in a year and just
your baby steps and your plan if it's
changed hello it changed his phone
connection which is gone now so you know
that it by the way there are two
different insurance companies that we
have found in the last 30 years that
actually teach a class called
intimidation selling where they treat
you like crap and you feel so put down
and you feel so much contempt if you
don't go along with their plan that you
buy it is an actual sales technique it's
one of the more growth
ones I've ever seen but it's an actual
sales technique so don't put up with
crap off a credit card company when you
call them to cancel your credit card I'm
the customer it's a simple transaction
close the dad-blame thing you idiot
you know I'm not gonna argue with you
I'm the customer I called up being kind
but you're gonna be unkind to me and
expect me to continue to give them you
my money and my trust not a chance
sayonara baby you're out of here done
with you done with you man so do
whatever you want but that's a pretty
low bar on that for me but I conflict
for breakfast on the talk radio host I
get that I understand other people are
nicer and more conflict diverse but I'm
extremely loyal but it ends when you
start treating me like poop I mean it's
a pretty simple thing he can't breathe
you probably told probably told him all
those lies though these whole life guys
they just make up crap I have Xander
Jeff Xander and I get together have
dinner
we have laughed so many times at how
many times he hears at insurance
conventions and how many times I hear on
the hate chats that are out there on
Dave that I own
Xander insurance or I own a portion of
Xander insurance I have never owned a
dime of it now he does give me money for
endorsement cuz he buys ads here on the
air but that's been happening for 20
years and pretty successfully I might
add but no don't own any insurance
companies nor do i churchill mortgage by
the way mike Ardwick would that would
come as a great surprise to him if he
found out I owned it I don't but oh god
you can't have you can't have an actual
integrity transaction especially if I
don't like you so I have to make up crap